para nuestra sección de economía nos
acompaña nuestra periodista
especializada en el tema Daniela
hablando Daniela Buenos días y
bienvenida muy buenos días María Clara y
Bienvenido sea también gracias
Comencemos hablando de una noticia
bastante curiosa porque Suiza estaba
hablando de un presunto cartel pero este
de fragancias y es mundial María Clara y
con razón los perfumes son tan caros Ya
lo vamos a ver la industria mundial de
los aromas está valorada en miles de
millones de dólares crea y elabora
fragancias finas para marcas como Calvin
Klein o Hugo Boss o Gucci Carolina
Herrera cualquiera de todas estas entre
muchos otros perfumes pero al mismo
tiempo también diseña el olor de los
productos para el hogar en empresas tan
grandes como project and gamble o
Colgate palmolive la agencia Suiza
antimonopolio puso la lupa en cuatro
compañías que en su conjunto representan
más del 60% del mercado mundial de
fragancias estamos hablando de la
estadounidense flavor sunfraguenses
estamos hablando de gi que es Suiza y
firme que también es Suiza y SIM Rise
que es alemana estas cuatro compañías
pues concretamente se sospecha que estas
empresas coordinaron su política de
precios prohibieron a sus competidores
abastecer a cientos de clientes y
limitaron la producción de ciertas
fragancias todo para Elevar los precios
por supuesto es decir si habrían Aliado
para aprovecharse de sus clientes Y así
conseguir más beneficios económicos en
lo que se conoce en el mundo empresarial
como colusión esto les valió fuertes
caídas en bolsa la semana pasada y
parece que puede ser peor porque esta
investigación no se quedó únicamente en
Suiza sino que ya trascendió fronteras
sí María Clara de hecho la Unión Europea
reconoció que allá no esta semana sin
previo aviso en algunas de las sedes de
estas empresas en busca de información
también el organismo de control
británico dijo que recopilaría
documentos y se puso como límite a
principios de 2024 para para entregar
una respuesta si los llegan a encontrar
culpables afrontarían multas de Hasta el
10% de su facturación global que debe
ser enorme seguramente lo es Daniela le
propongo que cambiemos de tema y
hablemos de la reunión que están
teniendo el presidente francés Emanuel
majó y el Primer Ministro de Reino Unido
Richie sunak Porque además de ser
histórica por ser el primer encuentro
entre mandatarios de estos países en
cinco años por supuesto están debatiendo
temas económicos que se espera pues
además de limar estas asperezas sobre la
migración de las que hemos venido
hablando en los noticieros pues Francia
y Reino Unido buscan mejorar sus
relaciones económicas que se habían
deteriorado con el brexit como usted lo
decía es la primera reunión de este
nivel desde que macron recibió a tres
amate en 2018 ahora hagamos un pequeño
contexto estos lazos económicos han sido
muy difíciles desde que Gran Bretaña
votó a favor de abandonar la Unión
Europea en 2016 y es que esa Isla está
en la costa norte de Francia y cuando
Londres y Bruselas se divorciaron inició
una disputa sobre la concesión de
licencias a Los Pescadores franceses que
históricamente han trabajado en aguas
británicas llegó a ver incluso amenazas
de sanciones y la situación pudo
empeorar más hasta llegar a una
verdadera guerra comercial sin embargo
al final Londres terminó concediendo el
95% de esas licencias que estaban
solicitando los barcos franceses y
mejoraron los roces y hace casi dos
meses Londres y Bruselas tuvieron un
nuevo apretón de manos a la luz del
acuerdo de Windsor que busca solucionar
esos problemas comerciales posteriores
las posteriores al brexit
específicamente en Irlanda del Norte
bueno Y si bien se han mejorado estos
problemas comerciales con Reino Unido la
Unión Europea sigue enfrentando una
difícil situación en cuanto a la energía
por eso la Unión Europea acordó reducir
el consumo energético
Claro que sí pues hubo conversaciones
durante toda la noche del jueves entre
los negociadores de los países miembros
del bloque comunitario y el parlamento
europeo al final lo que terminó
sucediendo fue que pactaron una
reducción conjunta en el consumo final
de energía en 11,7% para 2030 este es un
objetivo que creen que va a ayudar el
combatir el cambio climático y frenar el
uso de combustibles fósiles rusos Aunque
sí es menor que el ahorro que se habían
planteado inicialmente del 13% para
alcanzar estos objetivos sin embargo se
va a requerir que los países renueven
millones de edificios con corrientes de
aire que hoy desperdician energía este
proceso va a comenzar inicialmente en
las construcciones de propiedad pública
se estima que se va a renovar menos al
menos el 3% de su superficie total cada
año ahora este acuerdo va a ir al
parlamento europeo y los países de la
Unión Europea para una votación final
Aunque lo que Suele suceder es que una
formalidad y se aprueba sin cambios
bueno Y también la Unión Europea tiene
una medida de choque por la ley de
inflación en Estados Unidos sí ha habido
tensiones entre Washington y la Unión
Europea por esa polémica ley que
subvenciona ampliamente las inversiones
En tecnologías limpias pues Bruselas
teme que muchas empresas van a trasladar
sus inversiones a Estados Unidos este
bloque les dio entonces una autorización
a los gobiernos para que activen ayudas
a esas compañías cuando exista un riesgo
real de que se vayan los subvencionan
para que no se vayan del país bueno y
cambiemos a América Latina porque en
Bolivia están escaseando los dólares
desde hace varias semanas María Clara
este viernes se está cumpliendo el
cuarto día de venta directa de dólares
en las oficinas del Banco Central de la
paz las largas filas como lo vamos a ver
a continuación son ahora el Común
denominador pues la gente acude de forma
masiva ante las limitaciones de Divisas
en la banca privada la queja de estas
personas que algunos bancos no tienen
dólares y que sí los tienen los están
restringiendo a montos muy bajos u
ofrecen bolivianos a quienes quieren
cobrar giros del exterior y todo comenzó
cuando a principios de febrero un
reporte Indicó que las reservas
internacionales estaban en alrededor de
3.800 millones de dólares este es uno de
los niveles más bajos de desde 2014
cuando llegaron a más de 15.000 millones
según el gobierno eso generó
especulación e incertidumbre y por eso
toda la gente quiere comprar dólares
ahora Bolivia ha dicho pues que es muy
bueno que tenga una de las inflaciones
más bajas del mundo la más baja en
América Latina pero muchos atribuyen
este hecho a los enormes subsidios que
entrega para evitar las fluctuaciones en
los precios Qué hacen estos subsidios
que ayudan a la inflación pero también
de sangran las reservas internacionales
Daniela y para este viernes tenemos una
cifra positiva o negativa bueno es una
cifra positiva para una persona y
negativa para muchas otras 12 millones
de dólares Esto es lo equivalente
esterlinas a la remuneración total del
presidente ejecutivo de British
petroleum Bernard Luna para 2022 este
salario María Clara se duplicó con
creces frente a los poco más de cinco
millones de dólares que había ganado en
2021 según el informe anual de la
petrolera británica que además dice que
tuvo una ganancia récord de 28 mil
millones de dólares bastante polémico
esto de las petroleras ganando y
beneficiándose de la guerra en Ucrania
bastante Daniela y una pregunta su
salario se acerca a esos 12 millones de
dólares nunca se va a acercar a esos 12
millones de dólares bueno Daniela
gracias por este dato y toda la
información económica volvemos con más
dentro de